flooding of historic proportions and
Mississippi has forced the governor to
declare a state of emergency
the rising Pearl River has already
affected at least 300 homes and the
worst may still be ahead officials in
the state capital of Jackson expect the
river to crest at its highest point in
more than 35 years
Omar Villafranca is in Jackson Omar
what's the situation looking like where
you are a good morning this water is
expected to rise another seven inches
and hundreds of homes and businesses are
bracing for the worst like this business
behind me here you can see the waters
already on the stairs and they've
sandbag and put plastic on the front
door for whatever Mother Nature has to
throw at them now the Pearl River is
expected to crest later on today but it
could be until the end of the week
before any of this water starts to
recede Jackson's floodwaters filled the
streets and forced evacuations over the
weekend ahead of warnings that more rain
is on the way this is a precarious
situation that could turn at any moment
at least four people had to be rescued
from their homes as the fast rising
waters from the Pearl River flooded
entire neighborhoods you all know of
anybody that's still back here
emergency crews used boats to bring
people and pets trapped in their homes
back to dry land
as water was released from an
overwhelmed reservoir up river of the
capital which will bring another 12 to
18 inches of water into the river the
inflow and the outflow equalized
allowing for some relief on the
reservoir pull multiple vehicles were
caught in the flood as people waited
through knee-deep water others made
their way down the street paddling in
boats officials urged caution because
calm looking waters could mask
fast-moving undercurrents never praying
40 foot years ago I'd be paddling up my
driveway the threat is far from over
matter of fact there's more rain in the
forecast up to two inches and that could
actually cause some flash flooding in
this area
Tony more bad news Omar thank you very
much